an area of immediate concern on the
american scene is the use and misuse of
drugs particularly among young people
what is the meaning of the drug
experience
in discussing this issue dr frankel
draws a distinction between
meanings which are objective and
externally verifiable
and those which are subjective
for instance those that are made
available in a uh
in a state of intoxication by lsd
may well wind up in the same way as the
animals that had been used by old and
minor in california for their
self-stimulation experiments that is to
say they inserted electrodes into the
brain of rats and whenever the electric
current was closed evidently these
animals experienced something such as
sexual orgasm or else the satisfaction
of taking in food and now the animals
learned to jump on the level thereby
closing the electric circuit thereby
providing themselves with these feelings
of satisfaction then they became
addicted to this business they did so up
to 50 000 times a day and the remarkable
thing now is these animals that could
provide themselves by this by
electricity with the mere feeling of
orgasm or other satisfactions no longer
cared for the real partner sexual
partners offered to them and noble and
totally neglected the real food that had
been offered to them
once you take in lsd
suddenly the whole world
takes on
infinite meaningfulness
however
these are merely subjective meanings i
would say these are feelings of
meaningfulness rather than true than
real meanings and the danger is that
those who resort to this subjective
feelings of meaningfulness are
threatened to bypass and neglect those
objective meanings which are in weight
for them which are in store for them out
there in the world rather than within
their own psyche caught in the
existential vacuum in the existential
despair in the despair over the apparent
meaninglessness of life they resort to
subjective meanings and then neglect the
objective meanings that are still
available but neglected by them the
journey of life is a life task to be
performed and to be achieved and not
simply a subjective feeling right not
just an adventure in terms of
sensations
but an adventure in terms of unique
potentialities once we have actualized
the potentiality
we have rescued it into the past where
from nothing and nobody can ever rob us
it has become a reality forever for
eternity but the same also holds if we
have neglected it by past it then the
potentiality not having been actualized
is past forever is lost forever this
constitutes our
infinite responsibleness of course
nobody is capable of fully actualizing
each and every potentiality and thereby
he becomes in a certain sense in an
existential sense he becomes guilty
however this guilt belongs to the
condition to the human condition is
inescapable and we have to confess to
our fallibility
this is no nothing to hinder us from
going on to actualize values and fulfill
meanings but it is a warning
not to let past the transitory
potentialities what is transitory is
only the potentialities but once we have
actualized them we have actualized them
forever we have rescued them into an
eternal reality as it were